okay today I'm going to talk to you
about wiring a plug most electrical
appliances in the UK are connected the
main supply with a three core cables
this means they have three wires each of
them have a plastic coating and copper
inside the copper is the conductor so
that's where the electricity flows down
and the insulating plastic around it
just makes its just for safety so the
electricity is kept within the copper
and if we were to touch it we'd stay
safe because plastics an insulator so
what we've got to do is we've got to
know about these three wires and this
thing called a fuse so let's have a look
what we have on our hands so first of
all we have this brown wire here which
is called the live wire now in the
plug-in plugs we make sure we always
have the same color code so we always
know what we're going to get because a
live wire is the dangerous one that
carries 230 volts so that's carrying the
electricity from the main supply to our
particular appliance that's the live
wire if I was to touch that the copper
part of this I would get electrocuted
that 230 volts would go through my body
because I have a my body is at 0 volts
so that we have a big potential
difference and it could injure me or
even kill me by stopping my heart so the
live wire is the dangerous one and
that's always brown so next up we have
this blue wire right here and this blue
wire in our plug is called the neutral
wire okay so it's called the neutral
wire now a neutral wire its sole job is
just to complete the circuit so the
electricity flows into the appliance
here through the live wire and our
neutral wire just completes the circuit
this wire here is at 0 volts so if I was
to touch the copper part of this wire I
would not get electrocuted because I'm
at 0 volts so is this neutral wire
there's no potential difference between
me and it now in the UK we have this
third wire which is green and yellow
stripes
and this one is called the earth wire
now the earth wire is all about safety
okay all about safety this is how it
works
let's say a part of the livewire little
bit of the copper came came loose and
touched the appliance touch the kind of
sides of the appliance the whole
appliance could become live which means
by touching the whole appliance I could
get electrocuted so what the purpose of
the earth is is if the whole appliance
was to become live the earth would take
that current away from the appliance and
to a keeping us safe so the earth wire
is all about safety
that too is also at zero volts so if I
was to touch the copper part of this
wire would also be safe as well so those
are the three wires now we just need to
have a look this thing called a fuse
now all the fuses all the fuses
is it something is it again in there for
safety so a fuse is specially designed
to melt if we if the current gets too
high let's say there's a Fault in the
appliance or they get a sudden surge of
current this fuse is going to melt and
that breaks the circuit that means that
no more current can flow through because
essentially as soon as the fuse is
specially designed to have a threshold
of current slightly above the current
that the appliance works at so the
second that current gets slightly too
high the fuse melts and the whole
circuit is broken this here the fuse is
here for safety as well as the earth so
a quick recap the live wire in the plug
is the one that carries the potential
difference from the mains to the
appliance a neutral wire is always blue
and that completes the circuit forgot to
say the live wires brown the earth wire
is there for safety in case the case in
if the appliance becomes life this
carries the current
and finally we have a fuse which is
something which is specially designed to
melt and break the circuit in case the
card we get surge of current and it gets
too high
so the earth wire and the fuse are in
there for safety's sake thank you very
much